these are the five most indisputable fan
theories of 2013 everyone ready here we
go first up is Breaking Bad but don't
worry people who for some reason still
haven't finished the show there are no
spoilers here a popular joke online this
year was that Breaking Bad would turn
out to be a prequel to malcolm in the
middle' with walt eventually going into
witness protection and becoming hal and
the joke got so popular that Breaking
Bad actually brought in Jane Kaz Merrick
and shot it as a DVD extra and sure
that's fun to talk about but
logistically it doesn't really hold I
mean the timeline problems alone but
what if hell isn't a grown up Walt but
instead Walt is a grown up Malcolm
not only does it make sense that Malcolm
would grow up to look like Walt they
actually have a lot in common
they're both geniuses they're both
stubborn and they both look down on
humanity you guys are stupid plus they
both hang out with dudes and wheelchairs
case closed on to the next one Willy
Wonka and the Chocolate Factory always
had dark undertones but 2013 was the
year fans finally caught Wonka
red-handed augustus Gloop stumbling to
the river was supposedly an accident but
if it wasn't planned then why does the
crazy boat only have exactly enough
seats for the kids who are left okay
you're thinking one of the kids would
have just stood on the boot but then
what was Wonka's plan for this leg of
the tour if more than four people were
still alive he didn't have one because
he knew the kids were going to die let's
see Tim Burton try to out creepy that
you probably remember that Greece is a
sporadically vulgar musical about high
schoolers from different worlds but what
you might have forgot is that right
before the movie ends without warning
this car takes flight and soars into the
sky now we know from an earlier musical
number that greased lightning is a
pretty special car but there is nothing
in the movie that explains this until
now remember earlier in the movie when
Danny was singing about Sandy and how he
saved her life and how she nearly
drowned
well what if sandy did drown and the
whole movie was her dying fantasy and in
the end that's her flying up to heaven
why would she fantasize about all the
surprisingly dark stuff that Greece gets
into I don't know but there really is a
flying car at the end of that movie and
this is the most plausible explanation
for it I have ever heard
king of the hill never acted like a show
that was keeping secrets but maybe
that's just because they were so good at
it the Hank and Bobby father-son
relationship was the core
the show for over eleven years but what
if Hank wasn't Bobby's real father what
if Bobby's real father was Bill think
about it Hank and Peggy were told they'd
never get pregnant because Hanks narrow
urethra bill is obsessed with Peggy and
Peggy can't stand being around bill
maybe because of something that happened
between them in the past Plus don't
forget that bill passes the DOE tree
family recipe onto Bobby and bill once
joked in a moment of weakness on the
dark Friday night I slept with Peggy no
Hank called him out on it no you didn't
bill I know and of course you cannot
talk about the fan theories of 2013
without bringing up the unified Pixar
universe that puts all of the company's
films on one cohesive timeline is way
too complicated to get into here but the
gist of it is that ancient magics gave
both animals and inanimate objects
personalities the objects drove humans
from earth and then the animals evolved
and get more complicated because of
radiation from machines and then
eventually they become monsters again
this is just a summary there is so much
good stuff I'm leaving out like the fact
that the witch from rave is a grownup
version of a time-traveling boo so I
encourage you to read more at the link
in the description I know it all sounds
crazy but keep in mind this thing got so
popular that when you go to google and
type in Pixar the Pixar theory is the
first suggestion so it must be true or
at least as true as any of these but
what does true even mean when we're
discussing fictional characters I don't
know
go ask an English teacher maybe if you
show them this video they'll let you
watch Breaking Bad in class that'd be
cool